[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY CHANG: Hi, everyone.
I'm Andy Chang, I'm a product
manager on Google's privacy
and security team.
Really happy to be here today
to talk to you a little bit
about the lessons we've
learned from securing Google,
and from securing Google
customers on Google Cloud.
So enterprises today are
seeing an increasing number
of breaches, and the increasing
number of breaches being
reported in an increasing
number of ways in a larger
scope in the public.
And this trend does not
seem to be decreasing.
On a very regular basis,
the increase in data,
that's sensitive data that's
being collected, created,
combined with the
attackers increased
determination and
skill, is only going
to make this a larger
and larger problem.
So on average, an
independent studies
show that enterprises see
almost a million events
on a weekly basis, and that
reduces down to more than three
actual instance that
need to be investigated,
potentially remediated.
At Google, it's very
important, and we
think it's very important,
to think like the attacker.
So the attackers have a
particular kill chain.
It's part of Google
culture to do red teaming
on a regular basis.
And it was also part
of the informal culture
to do quite a bit of
white hat hacking.
These things allow us
to really focus and hone
in on what the attackers
are actually focused in on.
And so in thinking
like the attacker,
the attackers are
focused really overall
in trying to target
identities, the code, the data,
the metadata, and the resources.
On the identities, the typical
things that get compromised
are user accounts or off tokens.
On the code side, the
injection of malware,
they actually intersection
with even in the changing
the binaries, introducing things
into packages or libraries.
On the data side, just
the ability to kind of
egress sensitive
data so they can use
that for a range of purposes.
And on the metadata,
they'll look
for the attack on
cryptographic keys and secrets.
And finally from the
resource standpoint,
the really looking
at attacking things
from either denial
of service spaces
or subverting and abusing
resources for the purposes
of creating a command
control infrastructure,
or a botnets, or
cryptocurrency mining.
So all these are really kind
of where the state of play
is today.
Now at Google, we've been
very fortunate to have
eight of our services reach
out to over a billion users,
including Google Cloud.
As a result, every
moment of every day
we see the full range of attacks
that actually are going on,
and the full range
of bad actors.
So we see anything from lone
wolves and script kiddies
to nation state
actors to hacktivist
groups trying to attempt
to do the range of attacks
of phishing, denial of
service, malware injections,
for the full range
of motivations.
Could be economic motivations,
espionage motivations,
or just purely for fame.
As a result of that,
we've had to evolve
the culture and the strategy
for building security around
on Google, based on the global
scale in view of bad actors we
get while maintaining the pace
that supports the innovation
that the core products
within Google need.
As a result of that
experience, we've
learned a few lessons
of how to secure Google
and how to secure
Google customers
and enable them to
secure themselves
that we'd like to share.
So there are about seven
kind of key highlights
that we want to
talk about today.
And the first of those is
really defense in depth
by default at scale.
And that's protecting again
those three main issues
we talked about.
The identities, the data
in its three various forms,
code, user data, and
metadata, and then
the underlying resources.
And then trust
through transparency.
So not only is it necessary
and important to always
have leading edge
technology, in order
to build the trust with us
as customers and as partners,
we actually need
to be more and more
transparent about the security
infrastructure that we have.
Automation of best practices.
So on the development side, the
ability to take the user out
of the decision
making process, that
take developers out of
bespoke creating things,
to actually automate
the practices
so they get the best and most
secure things by default.
And then similarly. a core
part of Google culture
is being open and
sharing innovation,
and that's a core part
of the security culture.
We very much believe that
a safer for Web for all
is beneficial for the
masses and for everyone.
And our ability to take the
number of our innovations
and either open source
them, open standard them,
or make them available to the
public increases and raises,
is the tie that
raises a lot of votes.
On the user side, it's
important to address,
programmatically,
common use cases.
So again, that we take the user
out of the decision process,
and that common things
like patches and updates
occur programmatically
and by default. Finally,
from a security standpoint
in a public cloud in customer
environment, its
important for us
to first be clear about where
the shared responsibility
line is, and really to
empower our customers
to deliver on their part
of that responsibility.
And lastly, with all of these
things in combination, trust
and security you can really
be an accelerant to business.
And so now I'm going to talk
about a bunch of these things
in a bit more detail.
So historically, users
customers and partners
have really depended on the
network as that key barrier
for security.
And they really had
an intellectual model
of the villains being
kept outside and then
all the targets and things they
want to protect be kept inside.
But that model is broken.
Today, if either someone
gets inside or someone
starts inside the wire,
there are fundamentally
far fewer obstacles, controls,
and defenses for them.
And enterprises are seeing
that in their day to day life.
As enterprises now perforate
their own perimeters,
to use cloud services,
to allow mobile access,
this kind of core
perimeter model is broken.
Now Google for
quite a while now,
we've not had a
perimeter based model.
We do not believe that
there is an abstraction that
allows you to say there's
an outside and an inside.
In fact, our solution is
a perimeter-less model,
based on the fact that we can
do identity and authentication
and policy on each
access to every resource.
And we've talked about that
in our BeyondCorp papers
that we've published over
the last three to four years.
A key part of that is that many
of the services Google delivers
are public to the
public web by nature.
So in order to keep a
security level high enough
to protect the users
using those services,
we've had to build
a defense in depth
at scale by default structure.
And we'll talk about it
infrastructure in a moment.
So the first lesson.
Integrate the defense in depth
at scale by default. At Google
when we think about the
defense of our infrastructure,
we really think about
map to nine layers.
From hardware,
through secure boot,
to inner process communications,
and the curated operating
system, to the storage
and data services,
the network that Eric and Diane
talked about earlier today,
application level security,
deployment, operations,
and old data usage.
So at each layer of
these, we've designed
so that we can have
provenance and minimal trust
between each layer, which
allows us to then know
that as an application spins
up or as the hardware spins up,
it's built on an increasingly
trusted and known platform,
so that when it
finally operates,
it's operating in the situation
where the right code is
authorized by the right service,
running on the right machine,
accessing the right
data at the right time,
and in the right context.
That's a core part
of every operation
that occurs at Google.
To dive us in a
little bit more depth,
we're going to talk about
many of the layers that
form the underlying layer,
so that the hardware level--
and we're very fortunate that
we have a large enough scale
that we can build
purpose built hardware.
And that means from purpose
built chips going into purpose
built servers, into purpose
built storage, into personal
built networking, into purpose
built and wholly owned data
centers that we
operate globally.
After we have the
provenance therefore
in the supply chain
of those servers,
the next step is to boot
in a trusted fashion.
So we cryptographically sign
the boot, the boot loader, all
the way up to the basic kernel.
And therefore allows us
to now have a machine
state, which is in
a known good state
with a unique
cryptographic identity that
then allows us to determine
that it's ready to be joined
to the fleet.
Once it's kind of at
that point, we also
have our own curated
and hardened version
of KVM, which we
spent a lot of time
through both code analysis,
fuzzing, and actually
changes and
modifications the code
to make sure that
that's a secure core
basis for our hardware and
software infrastructure.
We have authentication
and cryptographic way
between services
at this low level.
And then we want a
curated image of Unix,
again that's been
stripped out, oh sorry,
of Linux that's been stripped
out of many of the known
vulnerabilities.
In all these cases of known
vulnerabilities we've found,
we've also published back
out to the security community
so that the world at large
can benefit from this.
So now we're at a point where
we have trusted hardware,
it's boosted in trusted state,
and underlying host software
is something we have
high confidence in.
At a storage level, we encrypt
everything at risk by default,
in one or more different ways.
We have underlying,
obviously, disk encryption,
hardware disk encryption,
but on top of that,
add an application layer for all
data accesses on Google cloud
were encrypted at rest.
We additionally encrypt
in-transit between data
centers we own.
And we also allow that
ability to control the access
and logging of the data,
so through our set of audit
logs and also through
set of internal logging.
At the network layer, as both
Eric and Diane pointed out
this morning, we have one
of the world's largest
private networks.
And what that means
for customers is they
can connect with us at over 100
different points of presence
across 33 countries.
And from that point forward,
they're on a private network,
completely off the
public internet.
And we can guarantee
that end to end,
from where they touch
the point of presence
to the actual servers
and systems that
serve their applications.
In addition, once you
have the network in place,
next piece is really
the applications,
the applications that we build.
So within Google, we
have a software lifecycle
that programmatically enforces
peer review, security review,
privacy review, before
one line of code
is pushed to production.
And in addition, we use static
code analysis on our source
code, combined with the
ability to look at and scan
the libraries and the
packages that are linked in,
so that throughout
the build cycle,
in the manifest we have
a chain of evidence
and a binary signature
that allows us to know
that our code that's
about to be deployed
is actually the right code.
And this gets back
into I said earlier
about making sure
the right code is
running on the right machine,
which has an identity.
Authorized by the right service
or user who has an identity,
with those right
permissions, accessing
the right data, at the right
time, in the right context.
Once we're through with, from
an application development
standpoint, through the
software provenance,
through the ability to actually
actively scan that software,
the next step is to deploy.
And at Google, we have a
phrase that your first users
are typically abusers.
So there's always
the opportunity,
as soon as you
deploy code, to see
from a different set of
ways, the attackers trying
to find ways to actually
breach the actual software
you're creating.
And there are a number of things
we do on the deployment side.
First, for our
users, we enable them
to have a hardware
phishing-resistant two factor
authentication.
And we enforce that all of
our employees with access
to anything at Google use
that same hardware to factor
phishing-resistant security key.
In addition, all Google services
are encrypted through TNS, end
to end.
Google as an overall
infrastructure
has a Google front-end,
which is globally
distributed at different
points of presence,
but logically centralized.
And that gives us
the ability also to,
by default, have built in now
a service DDoS protection,
for a number of
things, like SSYN
flood, a lot of the
volumetric metric attacks.
And as a cloud
customer, if you use
one of the load
balancers, a product,
you're also protected
behind that.
As well as if you use
our platform of services,
such as AppEngine or
BigQuery, or software services
like G Suite, those
are automatically
protected from DDoS attacks.
In addition, we've
invested further
in the actual encrypting
and certification of traffic
between points through
certificate pinning, which
prevents man in
the middle attacks,
as well as moving forward
the work that we're
doing in an open way around
certificate authorities, which
allows you to have
an open record
and make sure that if a
particular CA gets compromised,
that that won't then be
able to be injected in
and create another
vector for folks.
So once things are deployed,
now we have to operate them.
And one of the core parts of
Google and our end of structure
is that we have the underlying
infrastructure from the host
side automatically
patched and updated.
And this is something
that customers
don't have to provide
maintenance windows
or see downtime for us to do
if they opt our live migration.
Because everything that Google
runs on a uniform substrate,
we're able to live migrate
user information around
while we're making either
maintenance changes
or importantly, these
patches and updates that make
sure everything stays current.
In addition from an
operations standpoint,
we have our own
threat analysis team,
which focuses on the
type of attackers
that we see targeting Google.
The advanced persistent
threats, looking
at the full range of
data we have at Google,
and look at the signatures
and the modes that they use,
so that we can better protect
ourselves and our customers
and our customers data.
And we have both a pre-fail team
focused on security engineering
and proactively and
preventatively securing
our applications, as well as
a post-fail team and instant
response, focused on actually
investigating and taking
those millions of
events and turning those
into deciding whether
those are instances that
need to be explored or not.
Finally from a usage standpoint,
as the applications are used,
we have the ability
through, again,
the data that we collect,
to look at login reputation,
to look at URL reputation,
in-app reputation,
things like Android store,
so we get a full sense
of what actually is
potentially a good binary
versus bad binary, what's good
behavior versus bad behavior.
And from a Google
Cloud standpoint,
we provide audit logging for
both access logs as well as
admin logs, so that
you as a customer
can see what's also going on.
So as a part of this
then, in addition to
the technology that
we've put in here,
we've also continue to
invest in the people.
So we have 700 plus software
engineers and security
engineers solely focused on
securing Google and Google
customers on Cloud.
And then it's the combination
really of the technology
and the team that continues to
allow us to deliver security
at a high level standard.
In addition, if you
want to learn more
about our infrastructure
security design,
I highly recommend that you
attend Niels Provos's talk
tomorrow at 5:30.
It's session IO243 and
he'll go in even more
detail around our
infrastructure security.
So again, the first lesson
from securing Google and Google
customers is it's important
to have integrated defense
and depth that's scaled
by default, which
means that from an
end to end basis,
you can establish provenance
and you know exactly what
code you're running,
and you know what
your known secure state is.
So lesson two is, in
addition to the technology
we just talked about,
and that's core,
right, it's a
necessary condition
to have leading technology
from a security standpoint.
For you as a customer and
you as partners to trust us,
we believe highly in trust
through transparency.
And what that means is that
it's a part of Google security
culture, that whenever
possible, we allow you
as the customer and the
user to decide for yourself
and have visibility
in what we're doing,
so you can make decisions
and draw your own conclusions
about how we're running
things and whether it's
appropriate to your business.
And some examples of this
are our transparency report,
which gives, on a regular
basis, a view of how
legal and public actions
affect sensitivity and access
to information on the internet.
In addition, we have an
ongoing and recurring effort
for increasing certifications,
so that once again, you
can either inspect
yourself or you
can trust and invest in a
third party that has already
validated what we do.
This spans the full range of ISO
27 001 27 0 17 and 18, SOC 1,
2, and 3, FedRAMP for a
number of our services,
especially G Suite, the ability
to do model contract clauses
with customers, and the
ability also assigned the case
for HIPAA for a number
of our services.
And this is an area
that we are going
to continually to invest in
and increasingly invest in
for the additional
certifications that
are prioritized by our
customers matched to what
they need for their business.
And also from a trust
and transparency side,
another piece of
how this is aligned
is to the SAP announcement that
we made this morning as well.
Partnering with SFP to deliver
governance, risk management,
and compliance
solutions, and also
partnering with SAPE so the
SAP can become a data custodian
of data on Google Cloud.
The third lesson is
really around automating
best practices to prevent
common mistakes at scale.
So as I mentioned
earlier, us as humans
are the source of many of the
potential issues and problems.
And so from a development side,
it's very important for us
to automate as much as possible
and abstract out the decisions
and choices our developers
have to make that may lead them
to create a less secure state.
As I also mentioned,
for most of our services
that we deploy in the public are
at the web application level,
so at the L seven level.
So a common area of concern
and prioritization for us
is in cross-site scripting.
So as an example of some of
the automation that we've done,
we have frameworks and we
have secure coding practices.
Combine those with
automated scanning.
And what that's allowed
us over a four year period
is reduce cross-site
scripting errors by over 30%.
And for some of our
billion user applications,
that's reduce cross-site
scripting vulnerabilities down
to near zero.
The fourth lesson,
and this is again core
to Google, both from an
innovation open-source
standpoint, is really
to share innovations
to the wider community
and really raise the bar
and lift the tide,
so that the web
becomes more secure for all.
Some examples of this,
Google has for a long time
been a contributor to
security and a leader
in the contributions
to security,
going back to TLS and the
Safe Browsing interface.
Our vulnerability
rewards program,
which started back
in November of 2010,
has today paid out
over $9 million
to security researchers, who
have found various things
and helped us improve the
security of our own platform.
The security key technology
that I talked about,
in combination with
the FIDO Alliance,
to again provide a phishing
resistant way that combines,
from a user experience, low
effort, and a high security
ability, so that actually will
be used and secure our users
and employees.
Project Zero, which is
an independent effort
within Google, which looks for
O days and third party software,
and has been instrumental
in driving fixes
to some of the key
vulnerabilities
that have been found.
And recently over
the last year, we've
actually open sourced our
vendor security framework
to allow you to
actually take advantage
of some of the controls,
some of the ways
we think about things when we
engage with vendors at Google,
to actually allow access
to our Chrome fuzzer
so that you can use the
infrastructure from a fuzzing
standpoint, and also from
an IoT beacon standpoint,
to extend from an open
format standpoint,
a secure and privacy
preserving beacon format.
And the one thing
also I mentioned back
in for our work in
KVM, each of the bugs
that we found in the KVM,
we've actually, again,
externalized and made
available to the security
community, so they
can benefit from that.
And I think to date
that's been, we've
found about over 2/3 the
actual publicized bugs
that have been found in KVM.
From a fifth lesson
standpoint, it's
also from an
operational standpoint,
to address common use
cases programmatically.
And some of the key
examples of this
is that while there's a lot of
press today around zero days
and around very sophisticated
advanced persistent threats,
most of our customers
and most partners
still have a lot of potentially
basic hygiene security
things that can be addressed,
such as patching and updating
and what users do to
secure themselves.
An example of our philosophy
around updates and patching
is, this is the last
three versions of Chrome
that have been released
over since September.
And basically what you see on
the x-axis is the week in which
the week by week of the
year, and the y-axis,
the percentage of adoption.
So within the first week of each
of the launches of our updates,
the majority of the
1 billion plus users
are updated to the new version.
And that's a core part of
both our Chrome and Android
approach, and also our
approach to patching
in our underlying fleet, is
that it should be an automated
process, it should
happen by default,
and therefore people get
to be secure by default
without having to take any
additional effort piece.
The next piece is focused,
again around users.
As I mentioned before
on the development side,
us as humans are some
of the weakest links,
and similarly on the user side.
Users and phishing is the most
common way that breaches start.
And again, talking to,
one of the key solutions
that we helped bring
to market is really
the phishing-resistant
hardware two factor.
You'll be hearing
more about that
in the rest of this conference.
And that's something that,
again, as employees of Google,
it's required.
It's how we access
and secure ourselves
to any access at
Google, and it's
something we highly recommend
that the admin accounts
at any of the, and if you as
users or anyone on Google Cloud
also use this phishing-resistant
two factor solution.
In addition, you'll
see most of us
at Google also use Chromebooks.
And Chromebooks are another
way that, by default, you
can be secure.
Chromebooks, there is no
way to download software
onto Chromebooks.
So if you think about
hardware resistant two factor,
the ability to eliminate, the
ability to install malware
on your machines, those
are ways, by default
again, that the community in
general can be more secure
and eliminate one of the
easiest attack vectors.
So lesson 6 really is
around empowering customers
to fulfill their responsibility
in the shared responsibility
model for security.
So for most of you
in the audience,
you're probably very
familiar with this.
This is the 2011
Lockheed Martin kill
chain for attackers,
which really
looks to provide how
the attackers think
about ultimately getting
to their objectives.
But to date, there hasn't
been a similar common view
of what the defender
kill chain looks like.
Some of the initial work on
that has really focused really
on post-fail, right.
Really on what happens between
the monitoring and detecting,
the ability to alert, and
then the actions thereafter.
If you break that
up some more looking
at just the post-fail
piece, work recently
at RSA from
Microsoft has further
expanded some of
the response choices
and giving us more process
and more framework around what
folks do on a response basis.
And if you look at the original
work from Lockheed Martin,
that also really focused
just on the response side.
So what we can do
to the attacker
killed chain, to either detect
it, deny it, destroy it,
deceive it.
But traditionally,
most of these things
have come from the
old world, where
a company has full control
of its data centers
and defensive structure.
And really, there's
only one organization
that's involved in
handling any incident.
As we've now moved to
kind of public cloud
and a cloud based world,
there are two things that
additionally need to happen.
One is increased, in
addition to that kill chain,
on the pre-fail
side, and having that
as an integrated part of the
overall decision on the defense
side.
So in addition to the
post-fail reaction,
how do we, together
with our customers,
assess and provide the right
assessment the attack surface?
How do we actually specify,
define what the secure baseline
is, and have that enforced
across on premise, hybrid,
and multicloud?
And then how do we protect
those uniformly too,
so there aren't any
chinks in the armor,
irrespective of what
the infrastructure is.
And then that feeds into the
protection, detection alerting,
and response.
And on the back end, one key
thing that historically, again,
has not been focused on, but
is more and more important,
is the communication aspect.
Historically when we talked
about instant response
and detection response, it was
again within one organization
and so the sausage
making was really hidden.
At this point in
time, when customers
have a shared
responsibility on cloud,
the distinction of the
communication paths
between the customer
and the cloud provider
need to both be
programmatically and processed
from a standpoint,
evolved so they actually
meet the needs on both sides.
And the last thing is really
the opportunity to learn.
So as both Diane and Fei-Fei
talked about this morning,
we're in the age of
machine learning.
So the ability to take
the data that we now
have across the cloud,
that you have as customers,
and use that to integrate
both in learning
on the pre-fail side,
in the detection
side, and the response side
is a great opportunity.
So what we want to do now then
is connect this defender kill
chain, this defender kill
chain, with those targets
I talked about at
the beginning, right.
So attackers are looking to
get out, again, identity, code,
data, metadata, and resources.
When you combine this, you
can create a framework, which
really looks at the
intersection of the two,
both in pre-fail and
post-fail, and now we
can have a very, very clear
discussion between cloud
providers and
customers about where
the shared responsibility sits.
So some of the key
places this sits.
If you think about where
audit and compliance sit,
they sit around in the pre-fail
assessment and specification
phase, that's what a lot of
audit and compliance is about.
In addition,
security engineering
sits in, similarly, how to
define from your development
cycle, the things that make
your code and your system
secure by design.
When we cross over to
the post-fail side,
that's really
historically been the role
of security operations, the
SOC, and the detection response
teams.
However one thing you'll
note purposefully,
is I haven't created a
overlap between those.
And that reflects what
life is like today,
but that's one of
the things that
needs to change as we
think about how to do end
to end security operations in,
similar to how folks ended up
doing development operations.
That overlap of
understanding what
you specify gets turned
into what you monitor for,
gets turned into
what you detect,
and what you are able
to then respond to.
And as I talked
about before, there's
a huge opportunity
from the learning
side across all of these, to
feed into the growth of this.
So let's take a test
drive of this in practice
and what does this mean.
So key intersections, again,
audit and compliance, security
around each of the
things, for example,
security engineering
around identity,
how does that become a
shared responsibility?
Around policy specification
and enforcement,
vulnerability management,
data protection,
logging, those are the
common topics that come up
in the shared responsibility.
And from an operations
side, the communication
and learning pieces.
Now when we map this to
identities, what we have here
then, just to orient you is,
right to left, on premise,
through to software as a
service, so the abstraction
the sense of control
for the customer
is going most on the
right, least on the left.
And then in the y-axis, the
stages of the kill chain, from
assess all the
way down to learn.
The color codes are what
the provider typically
manages in these situations,
versus on the green side, what
the customer manages.
And then the gold areas are
those opportunity areas,
where even though this is
a customer responsibility
and customer managed
thing, theirs
is where either
providers or partners can
help the customer achieve
their shared responsibility.
So what does this
mean in practice?
So from an identity
standpoint, assessing
the strength of your
identity and how
your identity solutions,
that's squarely
on the customer, that's
not something that really
cloud provider just decides.
But enabling the customer to
then understand and specify
what's the secure
baseline, those
are opportunities for
the cloud provider
and or partners to
help the customer
understand what their secure
state is, what the baseline is,
and do the reference from that.
As you can tell, as you go
from a software as a service,
where very little is in the
direct control of the customer
and the customer is really
using software created
by the provider,
there's a lot that's not
the customer's responsibility.
In the platform as a service
case is where that gray area,
there's a number of things in
the specify and protect side
that end up being the customer's
responsibility, as well
as that in all cases,
that opportunity to learn.
And where most the folks doing
traditional lift and shift are,
are obviously an
infrastructure of service.
And throughout the spectrum,
besides just the assessment
side of identities,
the ability for us
as the cloud provider or our
partners to help customers
fulfill the responsibility
spans the whole spectrum.
And including a responsibility
around the communication
on the underlying
learning pieces.
And this kind of pattern is
largely the same from a data
standpoint.
The addition opportunity
from a data standpoint
is that cloud providers, and
we talked about this earlier
in terms of a content
awareness, have the ability
to also assist customers
in their ability
to understand what
data content they have,
what the policies there are,
and I'll talk more about that.
And finally from a
resource standpoint.
So if you're talking
the underlying resources
to deliver services.
On a software as a
service basis for example,
with something like
Drive or G-mail,
the customer really doesn't
have responsibilities
to protect those resources.
Those are auto-scaled resources
that the cloud provider
is managing.
Similarly, in a
platform as a service,
these are operationally
things that the cloud provider
provides.
Once you move to
infrastructure as service
throughout the full spectrum,
as a cloud provider,
and with our partners,
we have ability
to assist you as a
customer about how
you want to run and secure your
resource of infrastructures,
whether it's against
denial of service,
whether it's against abuse,
and those type things.
So kind of the last lesson is to
take that shared responsibility
model and talk
about what does that
mean for creating a trusted,
underlying, infrastructure
for you as a customer.
And they're really focused
around three things.
Context aware access, so getting
back to what we talked about
within Google, we do the
right code is running
on the right machine,
authorized by the right user,
running at the right time,
and in the right context.
Being able to
externalize that for you
as customers, to be
the same type of access
control that you guys provide.
From a content aware
standpoint, the ability
to not only look
at data and think
about the encryption
of it, but also
think about the
classification of it
and also differentially both
specify and enforce policy
against that data,
is an opportunity
that exists now in the
public cloud as data
gets moved to that.
That's much harder
for you guys to start
in practice in your existing
on prem infrastructures.
And lastly, platform trust.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about where
we're thinking further on
the platform trust side.
So trust and
security historically
have been looked at as things
that slow down innovation.
Our firm belief at
Google and something
that we've lived
through, keeping up
with the velocity of
our production teams,
is that once you have the
right set of trust and security
by default, you actually
accelerate innovation,
because that allows
developers to focus
on their kind of core
practice, which is delivering
and building great applications
that drive business,
and that the underlying
infrastructure
protects them and protects
their applications.
And Eric talked about this
earlier in the keynote.
That is the model that
we use at Google, that's
the model that we think
will, in the long term,
be the right one for
folks building businesses.
In order to do that, the three
components that we see really,
are context aware secure access.
So really extending beyond
this perimeter model
to allow individual
resources to have policy
applied at the moment to
use against their identity.
Content aware data management.
So as you all know,
the nature of the data,
what's actually in the data,
typically dictates its risk.
So being able to make users
and customers more easily
aware of what that content is
and manage that so they can
match differential policies.
And from a platform
trust standpoint,
the two kind of key principles.
One we talked
about before, which
is the trust through
transparency,
the more we are able to show
you and have you validate
what we do, the
higher level of trust
that you'll have
the ability to run
your businesses as our
platform, and also enabling
minimal required trust.
So how do we increase
the portfolio of items
that you can choose to do
without even having to trust
Google or the cloud provider.
So these are the areas
that we're looking
at kind of moving forward.
So kind of in summary.
Defense in depth is
really around allowing
the infrastructure to
be secure by default
and then allowing users,
developers, clients,
and partners to
really focus on what
they do best, which is creating
what's next and building
businesses.
The trust through
transparency piece
enables you to see and
verify for yourself,
and therefore make
decisions in an informed
way about whether you want to
run certain business processes
and workloads on
certain configurations.
Automation abstraction takes
humans out of the process
and creates repeatability
and deliverability at scale.
Our core values around open
sourcing and sharing innovation
are really around uplifting
the whole internet
and making it
safer for everyone.
And then from the
user standpoint,
to take again that
decision making choice out
of things like updates,
patching, access,
so that the common use cases
are addressed programmatically
and folks are secure by
default. Empowering customers
to secure themselves.
So being clear about the shared
responsibility model, enabling
kind of a successful
shared responsibility
by providing a full range
of services that allow
customers to deliver
on their part.
And lastly, to accelerate
and continue to create you
security as an
accelerant, the ability
to focus on context awareness,
content awareness, and then
platform trust.
So a core part of where we
are as an enterprise, working
with enterprises, is not only
to enable you to kind of get
to where you want to go, but
to start with meeting you
where you are, and
then taking you
beyond where you can imagine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]